hi there everyone in this video i'm
going to take you through everything you
need to know
to tune your bl heli 32 esc
to get the maximum performance out of
the motors on your quadcopter
now i know that there are lots of
different esc firmwares available
and that not all of you are going to be
flying blheli32
i would ask that anyone who's familiar
with other esc firmwares
if you could leave a suggestion in the
comments as to how to translate what i'm
talking about in this video
to other firmwares i'd really appreciate
it
now without any further ado let's get
into it
okay so to start with i'm going to take
you through the process
of connecting to your blheli 32 esc
so the first thing you're going to want
to do is go to this web address
i'll put a link down in the video
description and this is where you can
download
bl heli suite 32 now
don't be confused by this bl heli suite
that's for bl heli
s esc's and we're talking about bl heli
32 esc's in this video
so pick one of these three mac linux or
windows
and go ahead and download it the
download buttons up here
once you've downloaded it go to the
folder where you've downloaded the file
and extract the zip folder then go
into that folder and you should see this
list of files
you want the exe file so just double
click on that
and run it and you'll it'll bring up
this window
now this is the point where you're going
to want to connect your quad to your
computer
so plug the flight controller into the
computer by usb
and then plug in a battery
it's best to make sure your props are
off for this
once you've got the battery plugged in
go back to this window blhe suite 32
and look down at the bottom you'll see a
port and a baud rate
leave the board rate at default go to
the port and select
the com port that is your flight
controller and click
connect
then once that's worked click read setup
you should see four escs detected if
you've got
a quadcopter so
if that's all working and you click ok
you should see
all of these options and we're going to
be going through some of the most
important of these options that you
might want to
tune for your particular build in the
rest of this video
you'll want to check that you're on the
latest version of blheli32 and you can
see that revision number here
32.8 if you're on 32.7 or an earlier
version
you might want to update your esc and
the way you do that is by going to this
button
flash blheli
selecting the latest revision for your
esc
and then clicking ok
once you have the settings set the way
you want them
click this right setup button to write
the settings
to your escs
and you should see an information window
here i've got nothing to update here
because i haven't changed any settings
but it should update for you
now before i jump into how to tune your
blheli32 esc
i wanted to take a moment to give you
some background on
how bldc motors work because i think
this information
makes the settings in blheli32 make a
lot more sense
so this schematic shows a 12n 14p
brushless dc outrunner motor and this is
the typical type of motor that's used
in the majority of mini quads the 12n
refers to the 12 windings in the stator
and the 14p refers to the 14 magnets
or poles that are in the rotor and the
phases there are three phases are
labeled
a b and c you can see a b
and c here the magnetic north poles
in the diagram are shown in a red color
and the magnetic south poles are shown
in a green color
so this is how the phases are usually
connected
you can see that there are two common
configurations a
star configuration or a y configuration
where the phases are all connected into
the center and the center is a neutral
point
that is not typically used in mini quad
motors because it tends to
produce a low kv and a kv of a motor
that is
lower than we would like for our
application
mini quad motors are usually connected
in a delta configuration because this
provides
a higher kv and allows you to get more
rpm
out of the motor you can see that we
have three motor wires
one two and three and the phases a
b and c are connected across the wires
so
between one and two we have phase a
connected
between one and three we have phase c
and between wire two and three we have
phase b
connected so you can see that the esc
can drive
current through any of these phases
depending on whether it connects
the wires one two and three either to
positive voltage to the battery or to
ground
and that is how commutation works the
esc
connects those different motor wires to
positive voltage
or ground and drives current through the
phases a b and c
now inside the motor the windings are
wound
either clockwise or counterclockwise
now here the capital a windings
are wound clockwise and the small
a windings are wound counterclockwise
and what that means is that when
phase a is energized by the esc when
current is driven through that phase
the capital a solenoids the capital a
windings
become magnetic south poles but the
little a solenoids which are wound in
the other direction become magnetic
north poles
and you can see that that allows the
motor
to push and pull
on both the magnetic north and magnetic
south poles
now this diagram here shows how the esc
commutates the motor now commutation is
the process of
energizing the phases with electric
current
in a certain order and at a certain time
to cause the motor to rotate
so i have this animation which shows how
the commutation process works
and if i can stop it at just the right
time okay
so here you can see that we have the
capital a
winding is a magnetic south pole
and that means that it's been energized
with positive current so we're
just here at about 90 degrees in the
commutation cycle and you can see that
it's a magnetic south pole which means
that it's pushing away
this magnetic south pole and it's
pulling on this magnetic north pole
and encouraging the motor to rotate in a
clockwise direction
now just a moment later the situation
has changed because the motor
outrunner has rotated a little bit so
you can see that now we have a magnetic
north pole being pushed away
by this capital a winding and the
magnetic
south pole being pulled towards the
capital a winding
and you can see that the capital a
winding has now
changed from a magnetic south pole which
is what it was
to a magnetic north pole and so that
must mean that we now have
negative current or reverse current
flowing
through the capital a winding and by
switching
between positive and reverse current
this allows the winding to commutate the
motor and make it rotate
if we look here when the capital a
winding is directly opposite a south
or in fact a north pole that's what we
call the zero crossing of the phase
and at this point the capital a winding
is not energized at all so there's no
current flowing
so you can see the different stages of
commutation
there's a stage where no current is
flowing
then there's a stage where we have
positive current
then back to a stage where no current is
flowing and then a stage where negative
current is flowing
and all the while the motor is rotating
and we go through a full 360 degrees of
commutation
every 1 7th of a mechanical revolution
so there are seven
full commutation cycles per rotation
of the outer rotor of the motor
and the reason for that is that one full
commutation cycle
is one pair of poles a
south pole and a north pole passing the
phase
and because we have seven sets of
north and south poles that means seven
electrical revolutions for one physical
revolution of the rotor
so as you watch this animation you can
see that
the three phases a b and c are working
together
to encourage the rotor to rotate in the
clockwise direction
and phase b and phase c are doing
exactly the same thing as phase a that
we've just discussed
they have positive current they have
no current when the zero crossing
happens
and then they have reverse current the
difference between
phase b and phase c is they're just 120
degrees
out of phase with phase a
and so all that means is they're doing
the same thing at a different
time in the commutation cycle
now you might ask the question why are
there three phases
not two or four or 50.
and the answer is that it's a balance
between performance and cost and
complexity
so you can make motors with fewer phases
but they don't have the same performance
they're more difficult to start
and um they have more torque ripples so
it's a noisier
motor there's more vibration and that
sort of thing so
that's not as desirable for what we want
to do and you can also make motors with
more phases than three phases
there are motors with four or five or
even 12 phases for different
applications
but the reason why we don't have
more phases in our application is simply
because
every additional phase you add is more
windings it's more complexity in
manufacturing
it's more fets on the esc it makes
everything more complicated
and so it turns out that three phases is
a really nice balance between
cost and complexity and performance and
kind of gives you the best of both
worlds
there's one final thing to say about
this period here
for a sensorless brushless dc motor
because the esc is actually measuring
the voltage on the phase
during this period here and it's using
that measured voltage
to determine when the zero crossing
actually happens
and that determination of the zero
crossing is how
the esc knows how fast the rotor is
rotating
and when it should energize
all the different phases so if there's a
lot of electrical noise
that can sometimes make it difficult for
the esc to detect this zero crossing
because there's lots of noise and it's
hard for it to measure the voltage
accurately
and that is what can cause things like
desyncs
so that zero crossing is really
important for making sure that the
esc stays in sync with the motor as it's
spinning round and round
so now that we've got the theory out of
the way let's jump into how to tune your
esc
and we're going to start with motor
direction and i think this is the most
important setting to know how to change
some motors might be spinning the wrong
way when you first
build your quad and this motor direction
setting
is really the only way apart from
physically resoldering the motor wires
to correctly
change the direction of motor rotation
now there are a few different options
here you have normal and reversed which
are the ones that you're probably most
likely going to be using
you also have bi-directional normal and
reversed
now bi-directional mode is only
used for 3d flying that's where you
actually reverse the direction of the
motor in flight for hovering upside down
unless you're into 3d flying
you're going to want to only use normal
and reversed
now to select which esc or which motor
you want to change the direction of
you come down here to this multiple esc
tab and you're going to want to
right click on the esc you want to
change the direction of
to single select it then change the
motor direction if it's not
correct then you're going to want to
write the setup to that esc and then
you're going to want to test that the
motor has actually changed direction
and you're going to want to do that for
all of the motors that are rotating in
the wrong direction
now just to be clear this is the only
way
to change the direction of your motor in
software
don't try and do it in the beta flight
flight controller configurator
you can tell it the motors have changed
direction there but that won't actually
change the motor direction you really
should be doing it here in the esc
settings
so the next setting i want to talk about
is motor timing
and to understand motor timing we need
to go back to the commutation graph
that we discussed earlier in the video
so here's the commutation graph again
you can see that
theoretically the ideal situation
would be to energize the phase
b here at 0 degrees so that's like the
theoretical moment that we would want to
energize the phase
but this motor timing setting allows us
to tell
the esc to energize the phase
a few degrees and these are electrical
degrees not mechanical degrees
a few electrical degrees before that
theoretical moment up to 30 or 31
degrees i think before
the theoretical moment when it would be
energized
so why would we want to energize a phase
early
well the answer is that each motor phase
acts as an
inductor because it's a coil of wire and
this means that it takes
time after the phase is first powered on
for the current to reach its maximum
value
and so to compensate for this lag we
must power the phase on
slightly before we need it and that's
what the motor timing setting allows us
to do
it allows us to power the motor phase on
a little bit before we actually want it
to be on
to give that current time to build up
you can see the effect of this lag here
in the graph
we have this switch closed where we turn
on the
the power to the phase but the current
in the inductor doesn't immediately jump
up it ramps up over time to its full
value
and then when we open the switch and
de-energize the phase
you can see that the current falls
gradually back down to zero
so what is the recommended motor timing
well faster spinning motors so the types
that you might find on smaller quads
do benefit from increasing timing
also slower motors can benefit from
reducing the timing
because the time for the phase to
energize of a big motor
is is less in comparison to the
rate of commutation than for a very
small fast spinning motor
where actually it takes quite a long
time
for the coil to energize compared to how
fast the motor is spinning
for most mini quads a timing of 23
degrees
which is the medium high setting in bl
heli s
or 23 degrees in bl heli32 is a good
starting value
increasing motor timing can help reduce
desyncs
and can increase top end power but can
also cause your motors to get
hotter decreasing the timing
makes things like desyncs a little more
likely but
can make your motors slightly more
efficient at the cost
of some power so i would say 23 degrees
for a 5
inch and if you're running very small
quads
you might even consider increasing it
even more from 23 degrees
and if you're running really big quads
like 7 inch or 8 inch or 10 inch
you might consider reducing the motor
timing um
down a little bit and you're looking to
find that balance where
the motors stay nice and cool but you
still get plenty of
torque and responsiveness and top end
power as well
blheli32 has an auto timing mode
which you can use it's typically a bit
on the conservative side so you tend to
sacrifice a little bit of power with
auto mode but that will compensate the
timing
based on what the esc is detecting as
it's
spinning the motor so that can be you
know a good thing
for for larger quads or very small quads
it kind of tries and does its best to
get the timing right
but it tends to be a bit on the
conservative side
so if you're not too worried about
sacrificing a little bit of top end
power
auto is probably a good solution for you
the next setting we're going to look at
is pwm frequency
and you can find that here there are two
settings pwm frequency
low and pwm frequency high
now when a phase is being driven
it's not just on at a hundred percent
the power to the phase
is being modulated using pulse width
modulation or pwm
and here's a graph of what that looks
like it means that in this area here
where the phase is energized it's
actually being
pulsed and depending on the duty cycle
of the pulse
that controls the amount of power that
the esc is giving to the motor
and that's basically the throttle
position so at 50
throttle you'll have a 50 on 50 off
pulsing during this period when the
phase is energized
at 75 percent it'll be on for 75
of the time and off for 25 and at
25 throttle it will be on for 25
of the time and off for 75 of the time
and that's happening only when the phase
is energized
now a higher pwm frequency can give a
smoother approximation of the average
voltage
that the motor phase is supposed to
receive
because the motor inductance is better
able to smooth out the pulses of voltage
now it you can see what's happening here
in these two diagrams
at 24 kilohertz at 50 percent duty cycle
we have these longer pulses and longer
gaps but at 48 kilohertz
the pulses are shorter and the gaps are
shorter
but the proportion of time
that the power is on and off remains the
same
even as the frequency changes
now having quicker pulses
leads to a little less torque ripple so
that's a smoother application of force
as the rotor is spinning but
it does cause a little bit of additional
heating in the esc
fets because fets heat up most when they
actually are switching between on and
off so
the more often you switch them the
hotter they get
torque is also reduced by
having these faster pulses because a
shorter pulse
allows less time for the current to
build up
in the in the inductor in the motor
windings
so the peak current and therefore the
peak torque can be somewhat reduced by
increasing pwm frequency
so it's a bit of a trade-off a higher
pwm frequency gives you a
smoother running motor and maybe a
slightly more efficient motor as well
but it's a slightly less torquey motor a
little bit less mechanical torque out of
the motor
you can see what's going on in this
diagram with long pulses
the current is able to build up to a
higher value
before then falling again whereas
with shorter pulses the current doesn't
build up quite as much and so your
average current
is slightly lower it's only slight and
that does slightly reduce your
mechanical torque
so my recommendation is to use the
variable pwm
frequency that's in bl heli32
32.8 the latest version this
variable pwm frequency allows you the
best of both worlds
so you set a minimum pwm which is 24
kilohertz
or perhaps even less for maximum torque
at low rpms
and then you set your max pwm to 48
kilohertz or perhaps even a bit more
to give you the smoothest possible top
end now that low pedogram frequency
is the frequency at zero throttle and
the max pwm frequency
is the frequency at full throttle
and it's just a linear scale between the
two
so as you increase the throttle the pwm
frequency
increases from 24 to 48
the next setting i want to talk about is
ramp up power
now this setting controls how quickly
the pwm
duty cycle is allowed to increase as
the motor speeds up now why is this
important
well when a motor is spinning it
produces
a back emf voltage that opposes
the battery voltage and opposes the
current flow
in the windings and it's actually the
electrical work
done by the current from the battery
against this back emf
that's what's converted into mechanical
power
now this back emf is really really
important because the back emf
also acts to limit the current through
the motor
and stops it smoking itself because
the current through the motor without
the back emf would be
so high that it would just cause the
windings to melt
now as the motor speeds up the faster
the motor is spinning the larger the
back emf
as the motor speeds up the back emf is
increasing the whole time
so how does this affect ramp up power
well if you were to suddenly greatly
increase the power that you're putting
into the motor
without first allowing the motor time
to accelerate its speed and build up a
bigger back emf
you could drive truly enormous currents
through the motor windings and that
could actually cause
damage to the motor or to the esc's
so this ramp up power setting prevents
that happening
by saying well when i'm increasing power
to the motor
i'm not going to do it all in one go i'm
going to do it a little bit gradually
and i'm going to allow the motor to
speed up
because obviously when you increase the
power the rpms are going to increase
and it's going to speed up and build
that back emf
and that increased back emf is going to
prevent
too much current flowing through the
motor windings and causing the motor to
smoke
itself so this ramp up power controls
how quickly that power is being
increased
ideally what you want is the ramp up
power set
high enough that you can access the full
mechanical
torque of the motor and get the motor
accelerating as quickly as it possibly
can
but beyond that there is no benefit to
further increasing the ramp up power
because once you've got the full
mechanical torque of the motor available
extra ramp up power is just
driving more current through the
windings it's just saturating that
magnetic system you're not getting any
benefit
from the increased current and it's just
causing extra heating
which will give you hot motors and could
cause your motors to smoke themselves
so the default value of 50 is
okay for most five inch mini quads um
but i typically find that the
optimum ramp up power for five inch is
more about
more around 20 to 30 percent so i
usually set my ramp up power at 30
percent
if you're looking to tune ramp up power
and find the optimum
value for a given quad what you can do
is start with a very low value i think
the minimum is 3 percent
and increase the ramp up power in steps
of five to ten percent
and stop increasing the ramp up power
when you no longer see an improvement in
the quad's
response in the air because what that
means is that
you've got enough ramp up power at that
stage to access the full
mechanical capacity of the motor and
adding more ramp up power above that
isn't actually helping it's just causing
motor heating
and i've done this experiment and i
found for me
that i certainly couldn't see any
difference
above thirty percent for my five-inch
quads and that's why i set my ramp up
power to thirty percent
now for larger quads ramp up power can
be typically reduced
from default so for a seven inch quad
or even a five inch quad you could
reduce it a bit
to maybe around fifteen to twenty
percent for a seven inch
and maybe twenty five to thirty percent
for a 5-inch
for smaller quads however there may
actually be a benefit to
increasing the ramp up power from
default because a
small motor will accelerate much more
quickly build that back emf
much more quickly and so that means it
can accept
a faster increase in ramp up power and
this can be really important for small
quads and tiny loops
to actually getting more responsiveness
more performance out of the motor
by increasing that ramp up power so if
you're running a smaller quad maybe
three inch or smaller consider doing an
experiment where you
gradually increase the ramp up power
from the default
and see if a ramp up power above 50
percent
actually gives you a little bit more
responsiveness from your motors
and obviously keep going until you no
longer see a benefit
and then stop and maybe go back a little
bit
that may give you a bit of a performance
benefit
so the next setting i want to talk about
is temperature protection
and what this does is it reduces power
to the motor if the esc
overheats now really the default should
be fine for this 140c
but if you're particularly worried about
your esc overheating for some reason
you could reduce a little bit maybe 120
or 100 degrees
i would say typically the default will
be fine
demag compensation is a setting that
modifies
some of the behavior of the esc related
to the handling of missed
zero crossings and for most quads
default or low should be fine
if you're having desyncs you can try
switching to high
and seeing if things improve but for
most mini quads that shouldn't be
required
you might find for very large motors
very large quads
um that there is a benefit to switching
dmag compensation to high
so sine modulation mode is quite an
interesting feature
this feature varies the duty cycle of
the pwm
at low rpms to more closely approximate
a sinusoidal driving voltage
so you can see in this diagram how this
works you adjust the pwm duty cycle
of the motor drive
and that more closely approximates a
sinusoidal voltage in the motor windings
for big motors that spin very slowly
this can make them a little bit more
smooth with less torque ripple
however it also does reduce the torque
slightly at higher rpms the esc switches
back to
normal trapezoidal drive
just because that's most effective and
efficient for
high rpm drive i would recommend leaving
this feature off unless you're running
props larger than seven inch diameter
and then you can maybe run an experiment
to see if it provides a benefit for you
what i would say is torque at low rpm is
critical for flight performance and we
really don't want to give any up
for mini quads and so i would strongly
advise for
anything seven inch or smaller leaving
the setting off
to maximize the torque at low rpms
the brake on stop feature makes your
props
stop instantly when you disarm the quad
because rather than just allowing the
prop
to naturally freewheel to a stop the esc
actually applies braking to slow the
prop down as quickly as possible
i quite like this feature for the added
safety benefit
particularly for large props which can
take a while to spin down
just because if you are about to hit
something
and you disarm you can be more confident
that you are not going to hit that
object
with the prop still spinning however
this setting may make it slightly more
likely
for the quad to get caught up in a tree
if you have it on
because if the props can't rotate when
the quad is disarmed
then that can make it more difficult for
a quad to fall out of a tree
while we're on the topic of safety i
would also recommend that you set your
quad up
as i do so that whenever you arm the
quad
the props are always spinning so that
you know when the quad is armed that no
one is going to go and approach it
there are some settings in beta flight
that allow you to have
motors stopped while the quad is armed
and
i think that adds a little bit of risk
so there are a few settings here that
you need to leave at default but i'll go
through and tell you what they all do
so low voltage protection turns
off the esc when the battery voltage
falls below a certain level
now for a plane this is really useful
because
it just means that you can glide the
plane into a landing and not cook your
battery
but for a mini quad the moment the esc
turns off your quad is going to fall out
of the sky so
i would always leave low voltage
protection off and that way
you'll kill your battery but you might
just get your quad home and that's the
most important thing
current protection this will limit the
motor power if the current through the
esc
is over a certain level and initially
this might seem like a good idea
but actually there are lots of
situations where you get very short
spikes of current
through the motor particularly when the
motor is changing speed or if you clip
something
and in that situation it's actually you
don't want
the current to be limited because you
want the motor to to be able to recover
as quickly as possible
so i would typically leave current
protection off and
the current consumption of the motor is
then really going to be controlled by
ramp up power so if you have that set
correctly
you shouldn't need current protection on
current sense calibration um i guess
that's if you've got a digital current
sensor
and you're you're calibrating it my
esc's all have analog current sensing
so i don't really use this setting um
non-damped mode for many quads you want
to leave this
off you don't want to switch it on
because it will make the
quad respond really horribly in the air
basically if you turn this
on it will turn off the active braking
of the esc
and active braking is really important
so just leave this at default and off
stall protection at normal i've never
seen a reason to change that
auto telemetry you can leave that off
because
beta flight will turn on telemetry by
itself when it connects with the esc
s bus channel and s port physical id um
if you've got this connected to a beta
flight flight controller just
leave these at off because your flight
controller
is going to be dealing with the s bus
and s port and all of that stuff
i hope that you enjoyed this video and
that you now feel like you have the
information you need
to get your esc set up correctly to get
the maximum performance
out of the motors on your quadcopter if
you like the work that i do
and would like to support me i have a
patreon
as a patron you will get access to a
discord server where you can discuss
these topics with me
and other like-minded pilots patrons
also get
sneak peeks of some of the things that
i'm working on
at the moment that's a seven inch long
range frame
a new type of carbon fiber and i'm just
about to start
a five inch racing frame design as well
so if you're interested in those things
please follow the link in the video
description
and sign up that's all i have for you
for today
so until next time i wish you all very
very happy flying
you